congratulations on being our woman of
the decade how does that feel I mean I
feel I feel really humbled I don't know
what I've done to deserve an award like
this but I'm totally going to accept it
and thank everybody from Glamour this is
incredible I've had a remarkable ten
years my speech was really interesting I
said lots of things I hadn't planned on
saying and but it's been a really really
fun night thank you to Glamour and and
everybody here it's been fun and my
parents are here my sister's here
Brooklyn's here so it's been great and
obviously you've been designing for a
long time now but do you still get a
thrill out of seeing people wear your
dresses and have you still got a to
dress list and there people still on
that you know I love women and I want to
empower women I want women to feel good
about themselves and seeing any woman in
my in my dresses is exciting whether
it's Jordan Dunn who's wearing one of
the dresses tonight who obviously looked
gorgeous or whether it's somebody that I
passed by on the street who isn't a
supermodel it's still exciting I want to
empower women and make them feel good
about themselves would you ever do a
high street collaboration so more people
can get their hands on your device maybe
at some point not right now because I've
got a lot going on and I've got four
children but at some point absolutely I
think the high streets great and what's
been your highlight from the decade can
you pick one thing or is it just been
been so blessed to have two careers it
would be hard it would be hard to say
what has been the highlight I I'm living
in the moment I'm appreciative of the
past and looking forward to the future
you know I've got a wonderful husband
I've got four wonderful children and a
job that I love so I couldn't be happier
I really am very happy and looking
forward to spending a little bit more
time together as a family now
I really am that'll be really nice we've
spent a lot of time apart because he's
been working and I've been working but
the future is very exciting he has got
lots of great things up his sleeve so
we're looking forward to the future for
sure
and finally what can we expect from you
in the next decades well I'm gonna get
older I'm probably gonna get a few more
wrinkles I don't know more categories
one would hope first and foremost I I
feel very lucky to have a family that I
have so I would like my family to stay
happy and healthy goodness I don't know
I mean I love fashion I really feel that
it's where I belong I've got a lot that
I want to do so I would like to expand
my empire for sure I love it I'm very
lucky to have a job that I love